the following is a conversation with
Roger Penrose physicist mathematician
and philosopher at University of Oxford
he has made fundamental contributions in
many disciplines from the mathematical
physics of general relativity and
cosmology to the limitations of
computational view of consciousness in
his book the emperor's new mind roger
writes that quote children are not
afraid to pose basic questions that may
embarrass us as adults to ask in many
ways my goal with this podcast is to
embrace the inner child that is not
constrained by how one should behave
speak and think in the adult world
Roger is one of the most important minds
of our time so it was truly a pleasure
and an honor to talk with him
was recorded before the outbreak of the
pandemic for everyone feeling the
medical psychological and financial
burden of the crisis I'm sending love
your way stay strong
or in this together we'll beat this
thing this is the artificial
intelligence podcast if you enjoy it
subscribe on YouTube review it with five
stars an apple podcast supported on
patreon or simply connect with me on
Twitter at lex friedman spelled fri DM
a.m. as usual i'll do a few minutes of
ads now and never any ads in the middle
that can break the flow of the
conversation i hope that works for you
and doesn't hurt the listening
experience quick summary of the ads to
sponsors expressvpn and cash app please
consider supporting the podcast by
getting expressvpn
at expressvpn dot-com / Lex pod and
downloading cash app and using code lex
podcast this show is presented by cash
app the number one finance app in the
App Store when you get it
use code lex podcast cash app lets you
send money to friends buy bitcoin and
invest in the stock market with as
little as one dollar since cash app does
fractional share trading let me mention
that the order execution algorithm that
works behind the scenes to create the
abstraction of the fractional orders is
an algorithmic marvel so big props to
the cash app engineers for solving a
hard problem that in the end provides an
easy interface that takes a step up to
the next layer of abstraction over the
stock market making trading more
accessible for new investors and
diversification much easier
so again if you get cash add from the
App Store Google Play and use the code
lex podcast you get $10 and cash app
will also donate $10 the first an
organization that is helping to advanced
robotics and stem education for young
people around the world this show
sponsored by expressvpn get it at
expressvpn comm / lex pod to get a
discount and to support this podcast
I've been using expressvpn for many
years I love it it's easy to use press
the big power on button and your privacy
is protected and if you like you can
make it look like your locations
anywhere else in the world I might be in
Boston now but I can make it look like
I'm in New York London Paris or anywhere
else
this has a large number of obvious
benefits certainly it allows you to
access international versions of
streaming websites like the Japanese
Netflix or the UK who expressvpn works
on any device you can imagine I use it
on Linux shout out to a bond to Windows
Android but it's available everywhere
else to once again get it at expressvpn
comm slash Lex odd to get a discount and
to support this podcast and now here's
my conversation with Roger Penrose you
mentioned in conversation with Eric
Weinstein on the portal podcast that
2001 Space Odyssey is your favorite
movie
which aspect if he could mention of its
representation of artificial
intelligence science engineering
connected with you there also seems
there which is so amazing and how they
science was so well done I mean people
say oh no you interstellar is the this
amazing movie which is the most
scientific movie but I thought it's not
a patch on 2001
I mean 2001 they really went into all
sorts of details regarding you know
getting me freefall well done and
everything I thought it was extremely
well done so just the details or
memorizing and also things like scene
where at the beginning they have these
and said sort of human ancestors which
is sort of right sort of Eames eggs
becoming monolith
yes and well it's the one where he
throws the bone up into the air and then
it becomes this I mean there's just an
amazing sequence there what do you make
of the monolith does it have any
scientific or philosophical meaning to
you this kind of thing marks innovation
not really that comes from arthur c
clarke
I was a great fan of Ossie Clark so it's
just a nice plot device yeah well that
plot is excellent yes
yeah so how nine thousand decides to get
rid of the astronauts because he it
she believes that they will interfere
with the mission that's right no it's
this view I don't know whether I
disagree that question in a certain
sense he was telling you it's wrong see
the the machine seemed to think it was
superior to the human and so it was
entitled to get rid of the human beings
and run the show itself what do you
think how did the right thing do you
think how's flawed evil or if we think
about systems like how would we want how
to do the same thing in the future what
was the flaw there well you're basically
question touching on questions you see
it's just one supposed to believe that
how I was actually conscious I mean it
was played rather that way that's know
how and was a conscious being
because Hal showed some pain some
cognizant the hell appeared to be
cognizant of its of what it means to die
yes and therefore had an inkling of
cautious yeah I mean I'm not sure that
aspect of it was made completely clear
whether Hal was really are just a very
sophisticated computer which really
didn't actually have these feelings and
somehow but you're right it didn't like
the idea being turned off how does it
change things if how was it wasn't
conscious well it might say that it
would be wrong to turn it off if it was
actually conscious I mean these
questions arise if you think I mean AI
one of the ideas it's sort of a mixture
in a sense you say if it's trying to do
everything a human can do and if you
take the view that consciousness is
something which would come along when
the computer is sufficiently complicated
sufficiently whatever criteria you used
to characterize its consciousness in
terms of some can come
national criterion so how does
consciousness change our evaluation of
the decision the hell made it's not to
say that people have been confused about
this because if they say these machines
will become conscious but just simply
because it's the degree of computation
and when you get beyond that certain
degree of computation it will become
conscious then of course you have all
these problems I mean you might say well
one of the reasons you're doing AI is
because you understand the device at
some distant planet and you don't want
to send a human out there because then
you'd have to bring it back again and
that's cost you far more than just
sending it there and leaving it there
but if this device is actually a
conscious entity then you have to face
up to the fact that that's immoral
and so the mere fact that you're making
some AI device and getting that thinking
that removes your responsibility to it
would be incorrect and so this is a kind
of plot floor and that kind of viewpoint
I'm not sure how you know people who
take it very seriously I'm gonna have
this curious conversation with with I'm
going to forget names and I'm afraid
because this is what happens to me in
the wrong moment I've said I'd Douglas
have said this after and he's written
this book god I wish I liked I thought
it was a fantastic book but I didn't
agree with his conclusion from girdle's
theorem I think he got it wrong is he
well just tell you my story you see
because I'd never met him and then I
knew I was going to meet him at the
occasion IRS she's coming anyone to talk
to me and I said that's fine
and I thought in my mind well I'm going
to paint him into a corner you see use
his arguments to convince him that
certain numbers are conscious you know
some integers large enough integers are
actually conscious and this was going to
be my reductio ad absurdum so i started
having this argument and he simply
leptin to the corner he didn't even need
to be painted into it he took the view
that certain numbers were conscious I
thought that was a reductio ad absurdum
but he seemed to think it was perfectly
reasonable point of view with
out the absurdum there yes interesting
but the thing you mentioned about how is
the intuition that a lot of the people
at least in the artificial intelligence
world had and have I think they don't
make it explicit but that if you
increase the power of computation
naturally consciousness will emerge yes
I think that's what they think but
basically that's because they can't
think of anything else well that's right
and so it's a reasonable thing I mean
you think what the brain do what does do
a lot of computation I think most of
what you actually call computation is
done by the cerebellum I mean this is
one of the things that people don't much
mention and when I come to this subject
from the outside and certain things
strike me which you hardly ever hear
mentioned em you hear mentioned about
the left-right business they move your
right arm that's you're on the left side
of the brain and and so on and all that
sort of stuff and it's more than that if
you you have this plots of different
parts of the brain they're they're two
of these these things called the
homunculus which you see these pictures
of a distorted human figure and showing
different parts of the brain controlling
different parts of the body and it's not
simply things like okay the right hand
is controlled and since both sensory and
motor on the left side left hand on the
right side it's more than that vision is
at the back basically your feet at the
top I mean so it's about the worst
organization you can imagine right yeah
so it can't just be a mistake in nature
there's something going on there and
this is made more pronounced when you
think of the cerebellum the cerebellum
has when I was first thinking about
these things I was told it had half as
many neurons or something they're bad
comparable and now they tell me it's got
far more neurons in the cerebrum then
cerebrum is this sort of convoluted
thing at the top people always talk
about cerebellum is this thing just
looks a bit like a ball of wool to the
back underneath
it's got more neurons it's got more
connections computationally it's got
much more going on than this friend the
cerebrum but as far as we know although
it's slightly controversial the
cerebellum is entirely unconscious so
the actions you have a pianist who
complains incredible piece of music and
you think of any moves this little
finger until this was key to get a hit
at just the right moment does he or she
consciously will that movement no ok the
consciousness is coming in it's probably
to do with the feeling of the piece of
music that's being performed and that
sort of thing which is going on but the
details in what's going on are
controlled
I would think almost entirely by the
cerebellum that's where you have this
precision and they're they're really
detailed once you get I mean you think
of a tennis player or something does
that tennis player think exactly harder
which muscles should be moved in what
direction and so of course not but he or
she will maybe think well if the ball is
angled in such a way in that corner
there will be tricky for the opponent
and the details of that are all done
largely with the cerebellum that's where
all the precise motions but it's
unconscious so why is it interesting to
you that so much computation is done in
the cerebellum and yet is unconscious
because it doesn't it's it's the view
that somehow it's computation which is
producing the consciousness and it's
here you have an incredible amount of
computation going on and as far as we
know it's completely unconscious so why
what's the difference and I think it's
an important thing what's the difference
why is the cerebrum but all this very
peculiar stuff that very hard to see on
a computational perspectives like having
me everything have to cross over under
the other size and do something which
looks completely inefficient and you've
got funny things like the
frontal-lobe when the prett are where
did we call the Louvre and the place
where they come together you have the
different parts the control if you
wanted to do with motor and the other to
do with sensory and they're sort of
opposite each other rather than being
connected by a nuclear pie it's not just
though you've got electrical circuits
there's something else going on there so
it's it's just the idea that it's like a
complicated computer it just seems to me
to be completely missing the point there
must be a lot of computation going on
but the cerebellum seems to be much
better at doing that then the cerebrum
is so for sure I think what explains it
it's as like half hope and half we don't
know what's going on and therefore from
the computer science perspective you
hope that a Turing machine can be
perfectly can achieve general
intelligence well you have this
wonderful thing about during and girdle
and church and carry and various people
particularly Turing and I guess post was
the other one these people who develop
the idea of what a computation is and
there were different ideas of what a
computer developed differently I mean
church's way of doing it was very
different from Turing's but then they
were shown to be equivalent and so the
view emerged that what we mean by a
computation is a very clear concept and
one of the wonderful things that during
did was to show that you could have what
we call the universal Turing machine it
you just have to have a certain finite
device okay it has to have an unlimited
storage space which is accessible to it
but the actual computation if you like
is performed by this one universal
device and so the view comes away well
you have this universal Turing machine
and maybe the the brain is something
like that a universal Turing machine and
it's got maybe not an unlimited storage
with a huge storage accessible through
it and this model is one
which is what's used in ordinary
computation it's a very powerful model
and the universalness of computation
it's very useful you can have some
problem and you may not see immediately
how to put it onto a computer but if it
is something of that nature then there
were all sorts of sub programs and
subroutines when all the I mean I
learned a little bit of computing when I
was when I was a student but not very
much
it was enough to get the general ideas
and there's something really Pleasant
about a formal system like that yeah
well you can start discussing about
what's provable what's not these kinds
of things and you've got it you know a
notion which is an absolute notion this
notion of computability and you really
address when things what mathematical
problems are computed ly solvable and
what chance so and it's a very beautiful
area of mathematics and it's a very
powerful area of mathematics and it
underlies the whole sort of once I have
their principles of computing machines
that we have today could you say what is
Gaydos and completeness theorem and how
does it maybe also say is it
heartbreaking to you and how does it
interfere with this notion of
computation preciousness sure where the
ideas basically ideas which I formulated
in my first year as a graduate student
in Cambridge I did my undergraduate work
in mathematics in London and I had a
colleague Ian Percival we used to
discuss things like computational
logical systems quite a lot I'd heard
about girdles theorem a bit worried by
the idea that it seemed to say there
were things in mathematics that you
could never prove and so when I went to
Cambridge as a graduate student I went
to various courses you see I was doing
pure mathematics I was doing algebraic
geometry of a sort a little bit
different from my supervisor in people
but it was an area and I was interested
I got particularly interested in three
lecture courses that were nothing to do
with what I was supposed to be doing
when was the course by Hermann Bondi on
Einstein's general theory of relativity
which was a beautiful course he was a an
amazing lecturer brought these things
alive absolutely and now that was a
course on quantum mechanics given my
great physicist Paul Dirac very
beautiful course in a completely
different way it was he was very kind of
organized and never got excited about
anything seemingly but it was extremely
well-put-together and I found that
amazing too third course there was
nothing to do with what I should be
doing was a course on mathematical logic
I got I say my discussions were being
Percival was incompleteness theorem
already deeply within mathematical logic
space was were you introduced I was
introduced to it in detail by the course
but Burstein and he it was two things he
described which were very fundamental to
my understanding one was Turing machines
and the whole idea of computability and
all that so that was all very much part
of the course the other one was the girl
of theorem and it wasn't what I was
afraid it was to tell you there were
things in mathematics you couldn't prove
it was basically and he phrased it in a
way which often people didn't and if you
read Douglas Hofstadter's book he
doesn't you see but Steen made it very
clear and also not in a sort of public
lecture that he gave to a mathematical I
think it may be the atom Society one of
the mathematical undergraduate societies
and he made this point again very
clearly that if you've got a formal
system of proof so suppose what you mean
by proof is something which you could
check with a computer so to say whether
you've got it right or not you've got a
lot of steps have you carried this
computational procedure well following
the proof steps of the proof correctly
that can be checked by an algorithm by a
computer so that's the key thing now
what
have to now you see is this any good if
you've got an algorithmic system which
claims to say yes this is right this
you've proved it correctly this is true
if you've proved it if you made a
mistake it doesn't say it's true or
false but if you have if you've done it
right then the conclusion you've come to
is correct now you say why do you
believe it's correct because you've
looked at the rules and you said well
okay that one's all right yeah and that
one's all right what about that harm not
yeah I see I see why it's all right okay
you go through all the rules you say yes
following those rules if it says yes
it's true it is true they've got to make
sure that these rules are ones that you
trust is if you follow the rules and it
says it's a proof is the result actually
true right and that your belief that's
true depends upon looking at the rules
and understanding them now what girl
shows that if you have such a system
then you can construct a statement of
the very kind that it's supposed to look
at a mathematical statement and you can
see by the way it's constructed and what
it means that it's true but not provable
by the rules that you've been given and
it depends on your trust in the rules do
you believe that the rules only give you
truth if you believe the rules on you
give you truth then you believe this
other statement is also true I found
this absolutely mind-blowing when I saw
this it blew my mind oh my god you can
see that this statement is true it's as
good as any proof because it only
depends on your belief in the
reliability of the proof procedure
that's all it is and understanding that
the coding is done correctly and it
enables you to transcend that system so
whatever system you have as long as you
can understand what it's doing and why
you believe it only gives you truths
then you can see beyond that system now
how do you see beyond it what is it that
enables you to transcend that system
well it's your understanding
of what the system is actually saying
and what the statement and you've
constructed is actually staying just
this quality of understanding whatever
it is which is not governed by rules
it's not a computational procedure so
this idea of understanding is not going
to be within the rules of the sort of
within the formal system yes yes rules
anyway yeah because you have understood
them to be rules which only give you
truths they be no point in it otherwise
I'm a people say well ok this is what
this one said the rules as good as any
other well it's not true you see you
have to understand what the rules mean
and why does that understanding of the
mean give you something beyond the rules
themselves and that's that's what it was
that's what blew my mind it's somehow
standing why the rules give you truths
enables you to transcend the rules so
that's where I mean even at that time
that's already where the thought entered
your mind that the idea of understanding
or we can start calling it things like
intelligence or even consciousness is
outside the rules yes since I've always
concentrated on understanding you know
people say people somebody knows well we
know but about creativity that's
something a machine can't do is great
well I don't know what is creativity and
I don't know you know somebody can put
some funny things on a piece of paper
and say that's creative and you could
make a machine do that is it really
creative I don't know he said I worry
about that one I sort of agree with it
in a sense but it's so hard to do
anything with that statement but
understanding yes you can you can make
go see that understanding whatever it is
and it's very hard to put your finger on
it that's absolutely true can you try to
define or maybe dance around a
definition of understanding to some
degree but I don't often once it's about
this but there is something there which
is very slippery it's something like
standing back and it's got to be
something you see it's also got to be
something which was of value to our
remote ancestors because I sometimes
there's a cartoon which I drew sometimes
showing you how all these there's a in
the foreground you see this
mathematician
just doing some mathematical theorem
this little bit different job in that
theorem but let's not go into that he's
trying to prove some theorem and he's
about to be eaten by a saber-toothed
Tigers he's hiding in the in the
undergrowth you see and in the distance
you see his his cousins building growing
crops building shelters domesticating
animals and in this light foreground you
see they built a mammoth trap and this
poor old mammoth was falling into a pit
you see and all these people around him
are about to grab him you see and well
you see those are the ones who the
quality of understanding which goes with
all the it's not just a mathematician
doing some mathematics this
understanding quality is something else
which has been a tremendous advantage to
us not just to us see I don't think
consciousness is limited to humans
that's the interesting question at which
point if it is indeed connected to the
evolutionary process yeah
at which point is we pick up this very
hard question it's certainly I don't
think it's primates you know you see
these pictures of African hunting dogs
and how they they can plan amongst
themselves how to catch the antelopes
didn't some of these and David
Attenborough films I think this probably
was one of them and you can see they're
hunting dogs and they divide themselves
into two groups and they go in two
routes two different routes one of them
goes and they sort of hide next to the
river and the other group goes around
and they start yelping at these then
embark I guess whatever noise hunting
dogs do the antelopes and they sort of
round them up and they chase them in the
direction of the river and they're the
other ones just waiting for them just to
get because this when they get to the
river it slows them down and so they
pounce on them so they've obviously
planned this all out somehow I have no
idea how and there is some element of
conscious planning as far as I can see I
don't think it's just some kind of
there's so much of AI these days
they call bottom-up systems is it yeah
where you have neural networks and they
and they you give them a zillion
different things to look at and and then
they sort of you can choose one thing
over another this because it's seen so
many examples and picks up on the wrong
signals which your mom may not even be
conscious of and that doesn't feel like
understanding there's no understanding
and that whatsoever so well you're being
a little bit human centric so well what
exactly I'm not with the dogs Emma no
you're not sorry I'm not human centric
but I misspoke by a la biologie centric
is it possible that consciousness would
just look slightly different well I'm
not saying it's biological because we
don't know all right I think other
examples of the elephants is a wonderful
example to where they it's just I think
this was about that's number one
well they the elephants have to go from
along with the troop of them have to go
long distances and the leader of a troop
is a female they are apparently and this
female that she had to go all the way
from one part of the country to another
and at a certain point she made a detour
and they went off in this big detour all
the troop came with her and this is
where her sister had died and there were
her bones lying around and they go and
pick up the bones and they hand it round
and they caress the bones and then they
put them back and they will go back
again how am i doing that's so
interesting I mean there's something
going on there's no clear connection
with natural selection there's just some
deep feeling going on there we have to
do with their conscious experience and I
think it's something that your overall
is advantageous a natural selection but
not directly to do with natural
selection I like that there's something
going on and go on going on there yeah
like I told young Russian so I tend to
romanticize all things of this nature
that that it's not merely cold hard
computation perhaps I could just
slightly answer your question you were
asking me what is it
there's something about sort of standing
back and thinking about your own thought
processes I mean there is something like
that in the girdle thing because it's
just you're not following the rules
you're standing back and thinking about
the rules and so there is something that
you might say you think about you're
doing something that you think what the
hell am i doing and you sort of stand
back and think about what it is that's
making you think such a way just take a
step back outside this the game you've
been playing yeah you back up and you
think about yeah you're just not playing
the game anymore you're thinking about
what the hell you're doing in playing
this game and that's that's somehow it's
it's not very precise descriptive but
somehow feels very true that that's
somehow understandings yeah this kind of
reflection a reflection yes yeah there
is some it's a bit hard to put your
finger on but there is something there
which I think maybe could be unearthed
at some point and see this is really
what's going on why conscious beings
have this advantage what it is that
gives them an advantage and I think it
goes way back I don't think we're
talking about the hunting dogs and the
elephants that's pretty clear that
octopuses have the same sort of quality
and we call it consciousness yeah I
think so
seen enough examples of the way that
they behave and the evolution route is
completely different
does it go way back to some common
ancestor or did it come separately my
hope is it something simple but the hard
question if there's a hardware
prerequisite you know we have to develop
some kind of hardware mechanisms and our
computers like basically as you suggest
I'll get to in a second we kind of have
to throw away the computer as we know
today yeah the deterministic machines we
know today is it tried to create it
I mean why my hope of course is not but
well I should go really back to the
story which instance I'm finished
because I went to these three courses
you see when I was a graduate student
and so I started to think
I'm really I'm a pretty view what you
might call a materialist in the sense of
thinking that there's no kind of
mystical or something around which comes
in from who knows where you still that
yeah you still throw your life into me I
don't like the word materialist because
this is just we know what material is
and that's that is what is a bad word
because there's no mystical it's not
some mystical something which is not not
treatable my science it's so beautifully
put just a pause on that for a second
your materialist but you acknowledge
that we don't really know what the
materialist that's right I mean I like
to call myself a scientist that's the
first but it means that yes we see the
question goes on here so I began
thinking okay if consciousness or
understanding is something which is not
a computational process what can it be
and I knew enough from my undergraduate
work I knew about Newtonian mechanics
and I knew how basically you could put
it on a computer there is a fundamental
issue which is it important or not that
computation depends upon discrete things
so using discrete elements whereas the
physical laws depend on the continuum
now is this something to do with it is
it the fact that we use the continuum in
our physics and if we model our physical
system we use discrete systems like
ordinary computers I came to the view
that that's probably not it
I might have to retract on that someday
but the view was no you can get close
enough it's not altogether clear I have
to say but you can get close enough and
you know when to this course and I'm
Bondy on general relativity and I
thought well you can put that on a
computer because that was a long time
before people and I've sort of grown up
with this how people have done better
and better calculations and they could
work out black about black holes and
they can then work out how black holes
can interact with each other spar around
and what kind of gravitational waves can
add and there's still a very impressive
piece of computational work how you can
actually
work out the shapes of those signals and
now we have LIGO seeing these signals
and they say yeah there's this black
hole spiraling through each other this
is just a vindication of the power of
computation in describing einstein's
general as if it a so in that case we
can get close we would computation we
can get close to our understanding of
the physics you can get very very close
now is that close enough you see and
then I went to this course by Dirac they
see I think it was the very first
lecture that he gave and he was talking
about the superposition principle and he
said if you have a particle you usually
think of particle can be over here or
over there but in quantum mechanics it
can be over here and over there at the
same time and you have these states
which involve a superposition in some
sense of it different locations for that
particle and then he got out his piece
of chalk some people say broke it into
as a kind of illustration of how the
piece of chalk might be over here and
over there at the same time and he was
talking about this and I my mind
wandered I don't remember he what he
said well I can remember he's just moved
on to the next topic and something about
energy he'd mentioned which I had no
idea what had to do with anything
and so I'd been struck with this and
worried about it ever since it's
probably just as well I didn't hear his
explanation because it was probably one
of these things to calm me down and not
worry about it anymore it's in my case
I've worried it about it ever since so I
thought maybe that's the catch there is
something in quantum mechanics where are
these super positions become one or the
other and that's not part of quantum
mechanics there's something missing in
the theory the theory is incomplete it's
not just incomplete it's in a sentence
that's not quite right because if you
follow the equation the basic equation
of quantum mechanics that's the
Schrodinger equation you could put that
on a computer too there are lots of
difficulties about how many parameters
you have to put in so on it can be very
tricky but nevertheless it is a
computational process modulo this
question about the
continuum that's before but it's not
clear that makes any difference so our
theories of quantum mechanics maybe
missing the same element that the
universal Turing machine is missing
about consciousness yes yeah this is the
viewer held is that you need a theory
and that that what people call the
reduction of the state or the collapse
of the wavefunction which you have to
have otherwise quantum mechanics doesn't
relate to the world we see to make it
relate to the world we see you've got to
break the quantum you've got to break
the Schrodinger equation Schroeder
himself was absolutely by this idea he's
owned his own equation I mean that's why
he introduced this famous Schrodinger's
cats as a thought experiment he's really
saying look this is where my equation
leads you into it there's something
wrong something we haven't understood
which is basically fundamental and so I
was trying to put all these things
together and said well it's got to be
the non computability comes in there and
I also can't quite remember right when I
thought this but it's when gravity is
involved in quantum mechanics it's the
combination of those two and that's that
point when we you have good good reasons
to believe this this came much later but
I have good reason to believe that the
principles of general relativity and
those of quantum mechanics most
particularly it's the basic principle of
equivalence which goes back to Galileo
if you fall freely you eliminate the
gravitational field so you're imagine
Galileo drawing dropping his big rock
and his little rock from the Leaning
Tower whether he actually ever did that
or not pretty irrelevant and as the
rocks fall to the ground you'd have a
little insect sitting on one of them
looking at the other one and it seems to
think oh there's no gravity here of
course it hits ground and then realized
something's difference going on but when
it's in freefall the gravity has been
eliminated
Galileo understood that very beautifully
he gives these wonderful examples of
fireworks and you see the fireworks and
explode and you see the sphere of
sparkling fireworks this remains a
sphere as it
as though there were no gravity so he
understood that principle but he
couldn't make a theory out of it
Einstein came along used exactly the
same principle and that's the basis of
Einstein's general theory Elizabeth II
know there is a conflict this is
something I did much much later so this
wasn't those days that's much later you
can see there is a basic conflict
between the principle of superposition I
think that Dirac was talking about and
the principle of general Co very well
principle of equivalence gravitational
fields equivalent to an acceleration P
pause for a second what is the principle
of equivalence it's this Galileo
principle that we can eliminate at least
locally you have to be in a small
neighborhood because you see if you have
people dropping rocks all around the
world somewhere you can't get rid of it
all at once but in the local
neighborhood you can eliminate the
gravitational field by falling freely
with it and we now see this with
astronauts and they don't you know the
earth is right there you can see the
great globe of the earth right beneath
them but they don't care about it they
as far as they're concerned there's no
gravity they fall freely within the
gravitational field and that gets rid of
the gravitational field and that's the
principle of equivalence so what's the
was the contradiction what's the tension
with superposition uh well what so we
just a backtrack for a second just to
see if we can weave a thread through it
all yes so you wish she started to think
about consciousness as potentially
needing some of the same not mystical
but some of the same imagine see this is
a complicated story so you know people
think oh I'm drifting away from the
point of something but I think it is a
complicated story so what I'm trying to
say I mean I try to put it in a nutshell
it's not so easy I'm trying to say that
whatever consciousness is it's not a
computation yes it's not a physical
process which can be described by
computation but it nevertheless could be
so one of the interesting models the
you've proposed as the orchestrated
objective reduction yeah that's going
from there you say so I say I have no
idea so I wrote this book through my
scientific career I thought you know
when I'm retired I have enough time to
write a sort of a popular book which I
will explain my ideas and puzzles but I
like beautiful things about physics and
mathematics and this puzzle about
computability and consciousness and so
on
and in the process of writing this book
well I thought I'd do it when I was
retired I didn't actually I would didn't
wait that long because there was a radio
discussion between edward fredkin and
marvin minsky
and they were talking about what
computers could do and they were
entering and entering a big room they
imagined entering this big room with the
other end of the room two computers were
talking to each other and as you walk up
to the computers they will have
communicated to each other more ideas
concepts things than the entire human
race had ever commute
so I thought well know where you're
coming from but I just don't believe you
there's something missing that's it's
not that so I thought well I should
write my book and so I did it was
roughly the same time Stephen Hawking
this writing his brief history of time
and Hades at some point the book you're
talking about the emperor's new mind
that's right and both are and incredible
books the brief history of time and I'm
person you mind yes it was quite
interesting because he got he told me
he'd got some Carl Sagan I think to
write that forward good gosh what am I
gonna do I'm not gonna get anywhere
unless I get somebody so I know I know
Martin Gardner so I wonder if he'd do it
so he did and it is a very nice forward
so that so that's an incredible book and
some of the the same people you
mentioned Ed Franken which I guess of
expert systems Fame and Minsky of course
people know in the eye world but they
represent the artificial intelligence
that do hope and dream that
intelligences am i thinking well you
know I see where they're coming from and
they're like from exercise rectus oh
yeah you're right
but that's not my perspective so I
thought I had to say it and as I was
writing my book you see I thought well I
don't really know anything about
neurophysiology what am i doing writing
this book so I certainly reading up
about neurophysiology and I rate I'm
nothing I'm trying to find out well how
it is the nerve signals could possibly
preserve quantum coherence and all I
read is that the second electrical
signals which go along the nerves create
some effects through the brain there's
no chance you can isolate it so this is
hopeless so I come to the end of the
book
and I'm more or less give up and just
think of something which I didn't
believe in this maybe this is the way
around it but no and then you say I
thought well maybe this book well at
least stimulate young people to do
science or something and I got all these
letters from old people instead
he's the only people who could had time
to read my book so I mean except for
Stuart Hameroff except for Stuart
Hameroff you don't have a rough road to
me and he said I think you're missing
something you don't know about
microtubules do you didn't put it quite
like that but that was more or less it
and he said this is what you really need
to consider so I thought oh my god yes
that's a much more promising structure
so I mean fundamentally you were
searching for the source of a non
computable source of consciousness
within the human brain yeah in the
biology and so what are mark if I may
ask what are microtubules well you see I
I was ignorant in what address I never
came across them and in in in the books
I looked at that's I only read rather
superficially which is true but I didn't
know about microtubules Stuart I think
one of the things here was impressed him
about them is when you see pictures of
mitosis that's a cell dividing and you
see all the chromosomes and the
chromosomes get their gate or gate line
and then they get pulled apart and so
that as the cell divides the half the
chromosomes go you know how their web is
divided into the two pass
and they go to different ways and what
is it that's pulling them apart well
those are these little things called
microtubules and so he starts to get
interested in them and he formed the
view well he was his day job or night
job of where every call it is to put
people to sleep except he doesn't like
calling asleep because it's different
general anesthetics in a reversible way
so you want to make sure that they don't
experience the pain that would otherwise
be something that they feel and
consciousness is turned off for a while
and it can be turned back on again so
it's crucial that you can turn it off
and turn it on and what do you do when
you're doing that what do general
anesthetic gases do and see he formed
the view that it's the microtubules that
they affect and the details of why he
formed that view is not wasn't clear to
me but there but there's an interesting
story he keeps talking about but I've
found this very exciting because I
thought these structures these little
tubes which inhabit pretty well
ourselves it's not just neurons
apart from red blood cell red blood
cells they inhabit pretty well all the
other cells in the body but they're not
all the same kind you get different
kinds of microtubules and the ones that
excited me the most and this is may
still not be totally clear but they're
ones that excited me most were the ones
that the only ones that I knew but at
the time because they were there very
very symmetrical structures and I had
reason to believe that these very
symmetrical structures would be much
better at preserving a quantum state
quantum coherence preserving the thing
without you just need to cut preserve
certain degrees of freedom without them
leaking into the environment once they
leak into the environment your loss so
you ought to preserve these quantum
states at a level which the state
reduction process comes in and that's
where I think the non computability
comes in and it's the measure
process in quantum mechanics what's
going on so something about the the
measurement process what's going on
something about the structure on the
microtubules yes your intuition says
maybe there's something here maybe this
kind of structure allows for the the
mystery the there was a moment of chance
yes it just struck me that partly it was
the symmetry because there is a feature
of symmetry you can predict preserve
quantum coherence much better with
symmetrical structures there's a good
reason for that and that impressed me a
lot I didn't know the difference between
the a lattice and B lattice at that time
which could be important now that could
in medicine this year which isn't talked
about much but that's some in some sense
details we could take a step back just
to say these people are not familiar so
this this this was called the
orchestrated objective reduction idea or
orko R which is a biological philosophy
of mind the postulates that
consciousness originates at the quantum
level inside neuron so that has to do
with your search for where where is it
coming from so that's counter to the
notion that consciousness may arise from
the computation performed by the
synapses yes the key point here
sometimes people say it's because it's
quantum mechanical it's not just that
see it's it's it more outrageous than
that you see this is one reason I think
we're so far off from it because we
don't even know the physics right you
see it's not just quantum mechanics
people say oh you know quantum systems
and biological structures no well he's
starting to see that some basic
biological systems does depend on
quantum I mean look you the first place
all of chemistry is quantum mechanics
people got used to that so they don't
count that so you said let's not count
come on chemistry we sort of got the
hang of that I think but you have
quantum effects which are not just
chemical in photosynthesis and this is
one of the striking things in the last
several years that photosynthesis seems
to be a basically quantum process which
is not simply create chemical it's using
quantum mechanics in a very basic way so
you can start saying oh well with
photosynthesis is based on quantum
mechanics why not behave you have
neurons and things like that
maybe there's something which is a bit
like photosynthesis in that respect but
what I'm saying is even more outrageous
than that because those things are
talking about conventional quantum
mechanics now my argument says that
conventional quantum mechanics if you're
just following the Schrodinger equation
that's still competing well so you've
got to go beyond that so you've got to
go to where quantum mechanics goes wrong
in a certain sense you have to a little
bit careful about that because the way
people do quantum mechanics is a sort of
mixture of two different processes one
of them is the Schrodinger equation
which is a an equation my Schrodinger
wrote down and it tells you how the
system the state of a system evolves it
evolves according to this equation
completely deterministic but it involves
in two ridiculous situations and this
was much frightening it was very much
pointing out with his cat he said you
follow my equation that's Schrodinger's
equation and you could say that you have
two cat a cat which is dead and alive at
the same time that would be the
evolution of the Schrodinger equation
would lead to a state which is the cat
being dead and alive at the same time
and he's more or less saying this is an
absurdity people nod I say oh well
Schrodinger said you couldn't have a cat
with deadly it's not that you see he was
saying this is an absurdity there's
something missing and that the reduction
of the state or the collapse of the
wavefunction or whatever it is is
something which is has to be understood
it's not following the Schrodinger
equation it's not the way we
conventionally do quantum mechanics
there's something more than that and
it's easy to quote Authority here
because Einstein at least three of the
greatest physicists of 20th century who
were very fundamental in developing
quantum mechanics Einstein one of them
Schrodinger another Dirac another you
have to look carefully it directs
writing because he didn't tend to say
this out loud too much because he was
very cautious about what he said you
find the right place and you cease he
says quantum mechanics is a provisional
theory we need something which explains
the collapse of a wavefunction we need
to go beyond the theory we have now I
happen to be one of the kinds of people
there are many there is a whole group of
people they're all considered to be a
bit you know bit Mavericks who believe
that quantum mechanics needs to be
modified there's a small minority of
those people which were really a
minority who think that the way in which
it's modified has to be with gravity and
there is an even smaller minority of
those people who think it's a particular
way that I think it is you see so so
those are the quantum gravity folks for
what's well you see quantum gravity is
already not this because when you say
quantum gravity what you really mean is
quantum mechanics and Clyde -
gravitational Theory so you say let's
take this wonderful formalism of quantum
mechanics and make gravity fit into it
so that is what quantum gravity is meant
to be now I'm saying you've got to be
more even-handed that gravity affects
the structure of quantum mechanics -
it's not just you quantize gravity
you've got to gravity as quantum
mechanics and it's it's a two-way thing
but then when you even get started so
that you're saying and we have to figure
out totally new ideas indirectly no yes
it's you were stuck I don't have a
theory that's the trouble so this is a
big problem if you say okay well what so
there I don't know so we may be in the
very early days sort of it is in the
very early days and there but just
making this point yes you see Stuart
Hameroff
to be open Rose says that it's got to be
a reduction of the state and so so let's
use it
the trouble is Penrose doesn't say that
Penrose says well I think that no no we
have no experiments as yet which shows
that yes there are experiments which are
being thought through and which I'm
hoping will be performed there is an
experiment which is being developed by
dirt Romney Stowe who is I've known for
a long time who shares his time between
Leiden in the Netherlands and Santa
Barbara in the US and he's been working
on an experiment which could perhaps
demonstrate that quantum mechanics as we
now understand it if you don't bring in
the gravitational effects it has to be
modified and and then there's also
experiments that are underway that kind
of look at the microtubule side of
things to see if there's in the biology
you could see something like that could
you briefly mention it because that's a
really sort of one of the only
experimental attempts in the very early
days of even yeah about I think there's
there's a very serious area here which
is what Stuart Hameroff is doing and I
think it's very important one of the few
places that you can really get a bit of
a handle on what consciousness is is
what turns it off and when you're
thinking about general anesthetics it's
very specific these things turn
consciousness off what the hell do they
do well Stuart and a number of people
who work with him and others happen to
believe that the general anesthetics
directly effect microtubules and there
is some evidence for this I don't know
how strong it is and how watertight the
cases but I think there is some evidence
pointing in that kind of direction it's
not just an ordinary chemical process
there's something quite different about
it and one of the main candidates is
that these anesthetic gases do affect
directly microtubules and how strong
that evidence is I wouldn't
position to say but I think there is
fairly impressive evidence and the point
is the experiments are being undertaken
with yes I mean that is experimental
it's a very clear direction where you
can think of experiments which could
indicate whether or not it's really
microtubules which the anaesthetic gas
is directly affect that's really
exciting
one of the sad things is as far as I'm
for my outside perspective it's not many
people are working on this so there's a
very like Oh Stewart even it feels like
there's very few people are carrying the
flag forward on this I think it's it's
not many in the sense it's a minority
but it's not zero anymore
you see when I were originally serious
you know we were just just us and a few
few of our friends they weren't many
people think it but it's grown into into
it one of the main viewpoints yeah there
might be about four or five or six
different news that which people hold
and it's one of them so it's it's
considered as one of the possible lines
of thinking yes you describe physics
theories as falling into one of three
categories the superb the useful or the
tentative I like those words it's a
beautiful categorization do you think
we'll ever have a superb theory of
intelligence and of consciousness we
might we're a long way from it I don't
think we're even whether in the
tentative scale I mean it's uh you don't
think we've even entered the realm of
tentative probably no I think yeah
that's raised you know what do you see
the circle is so controversial we don't
have a clear view which which is
accepted by a majority I mean you say
yeah people most views are computational
in one form or another
they think it's some but it's not very
clear because even the the IIT people
who I think think of them as
computational but I've heard them saying
they know consciousness is supposed to
be not computation I say well if it's
not coming in what the hell is it what's
good what's going on but physical
processes are going on which
that what does it mean for something to
be computational then so is uh well
there has to be a process which is it's
very curious the way the history has
developed in quantum mechanics because
very early on people thought there was
something to do with consciousness but
it was almost the other way around you
see you have to say the Schrodinger
equations says all these different
alternatives happen all at once and then
when is it that only one of them happens
where one of the views which was quite
commonly held by a few distinguished
quantum physicists this well a conscious
being looks at the system what becomes
aware of it and at that point it becomes
one of the other that's a row where
consciousness is somehow
actively reducing the state my view is
almost the exact opposite of that it's
the state reduces itself in some way
which some non computational way which
we don't understand we don't have a
proper theory of and that is the
building block of what consciousness is
so consciousness is the other way around
it depends on that choice which nature
makes all the time when the state
becomes one of the other rather than the
superposition of one and the other and
when that happens there is what we're
saying now an element of proto
consciousness takes place proto
consciousness is roughly speaking the
building block out of which actual
consciousness is constructed so you have
these proto conscious elements which are
when the state decides to won't do one
thing or the other and that's the thing
which when organized together that's the
oh our part in orko our but the ork part
that's the the Oh our part at least once
can see where when driving as a theory
you can say it's the quantum choice of
going this way or that way but the ork
part which is the orchestration of this
is much more mysterious and how does the
brain somehow orchestrate all these
individual our processes into a genuine
genuine genuine
just experience and it might be
something that's beautifully simple
aware and completely in the dark about
yeah I think at the moment it's best the
thing you know we happily put the word
walk down there to say orchestrated
that's even more unclear what that
really means just like the word material
orchestrated yeah it's we know yes and
we've been dancing a little bit between
the word intelligence or understanding
in consciousness do you kind of see
those as sitting in the same space of
mystery yes you see I tend to say you
have understanding and intelligence and
awareness and somehow understanding is
in the middle of it you see it's I like
to say could you say of an entity that
is actually intelligent if it doesn't
have the quality of understanding nice
I'm using terms I don't even know how to
define but who cares really there's
somewhat poetic so I I somehow
understand them yes I think there's not
mathematical in nature yes you see as a
mathematician I don't know how to define
any of them but at least I can point to
the connections so the idea is
intelligence is something which I
believe needs understanding otherwise
you wouldn't say for any intelligence an
understanding needs awareness otherwise
you wouldn't really say it's
understanding you say of an entity they
understand something and it's unless
it's really aware of it in our normal
usage so there's a three sort of
weirdness understanding and intelligence
and I just tend to concentrate on
understanding because that's where I can
say something okay that's the kernel
theorem and things like that but they
what does it mean to be perceive the
color blue or something I mean I guess
it's much more difficult question I mean
is it the same if I see a color blue and
you see it if you're something with them
wasn't this this condition wants to call
them or were you assign a sound - yeah
yeah that's right you get colors and
sounds mixed up and that sort of thing I
mean an interesting subject um here but
from the physics perspective from the
fundamentals perspective we don't I
think we're way off pretty much
understanding what's going on there in
your 2010 book cycles of time you
suggest that another universe may have
existed before the Big Bang
can you describe this idea first of all
what is the Big Bang
sounds like a funny word and what may
have been there before it yes just as a
matter of terminology I don't like to
call it another universe because when
you have another universe you think of
it kind of quite separate from us but
these things they're not separate now
the Big Bang conventional theories yeah
I was actually brought up in the sense
of when I started getting dressed in
cosmology there was a thing called the
steady-state model which was sort of
philosophically very interesting and
there wasn't a big bang in that theory
that somehow new material was created
all the time in the form of hydrogen and
the universe kept on expanding expanding
expanding and there was room for more
hydrogen it was a rather philosophically
nice picture it was disproved when the
Big Bang well when I say the Big Bang
this was theoretically discovered by
people trying to solve Einstein's
equations and apply it to cosmology
Einstein didn't like the idea he liked
and I a universe which was there all the
time and he had a model which they wish
there all the time but then there was
this discovery
accidental discovery a very important
discovery of this microwave background
and if you you know there's the crackle
on your television screen which is is
already sensing this microwave
background which is coming at us from
all directions and you can trace it back
and back and back and back and it came
from a very early stage of the universe
well it's part of the Big Bang Theory
the Big Bang Theory was when people
tried to solve our science equations
they really found you have to have this
initial State
the universe it was used to be calmly
primordial Assam and things like this
there's freedmen and a la Mettrie
Freedman was a Russian the Metro was the
Belgian and they independently were
basically Friedman first the maitre
talked about the initial state which is
a very very concentrated initial state
which seemed to be the origin of the
universe from more Deol Adam that's the
primordial atom is what he called it yes
full term and then it became well Fred
Hoyle used the term Big Bang in a kind
of derogatory sense just like it was a
Schrodinger in the cat's right yeah it's
this like sort of geek tick got picked
up on whereas it wasn't his intention
originally but did then the evidence
piled up and piled up and my one of my
friends and I learned a lot from him
when I was in Cambridge just any Xiaomei
usually a proponent of steady state and
then he got to convert it just said no
I'm sorry I had a great respect for him
he went around lecturing said I was
wrong the steady-state model doesn't
work there was this big bang and this
microwave background that you see okay
it's not actually quite the Big Bang
when I said not quiet
it's about 380,000 years after the Big
Bang but that's what you see but then
you have to have had this Big Bang
before it's in order to make the
equations work and it works beautifully
except for one little thing which is
this thing called inflation which people
had to put into it to make it work when
I first heard of it I didn't like it at
all what's inflation inflation is it in
the first I'm gonna give you a very tiny
number think of a second that's not very
long now I'm going to give you a
fraction of a second one over a number
this number has 32 digits between well
it's it between 36 and 32 digits tiny
tiny time between those two tiny
ridiculous seconds fraction of a second
the universe was supposed to have
expanded in this exponential way an
enormous way for no Patera parent reason
you had to invent a particular thing
called the in photon field to make it do
it and I thought this is completely
crazy there are reasons why people stuck
with this idea you see the thing is that
I formed my model for
reasons which are very fundamental if
you like it has to do this very
fundamental principle which is known as
the second law of thermodynamics the
second law of thermodynamics says more
or less things get more and more random
as time goes on now another way of
saying exactly the same thing is things
get less and less random as things go
back if you go back in time they get
less and less random let me go back and
back and back and back and the earliest
thing you can directly see is this
microwave background what's one of the
most striking features of it is that
it's random it has this what you call
this spectrum of which is what's called
the Planck spectrum of frequencies
different intensities for different
frequencies and it's this wonderful
curve due to Max Planck and what's there
telling you it's telling you that the
entropy is a maximum start is often
maximum and it's going up over since I
call that a mammoth in the room paradox
and mother yes it is so people why don't
cosmologists worry about this so I'm
worried about it and then I thought well
it's not really a paradox because you're
looking at matter and radiation at a
maximum entropy state what you're not
seeing directly in that is the
gravitation its gravitation which is not
thermalized the gravitation was very
very low entropy and it's low entropy by
the uniformity and you see that in the
microwave - it's very uniform over the
whole sky I'm compressing a long story
into a very short sentence and doing a
great job yet so what I'm saying is that
there's a huge puzzle why it was gravity
in this very low entropy state very high
organized state everything else was all
random and that to me was the biggest
problem in cosmology the biggest problem
nobody seemed worried about it people
say they solved all the problems and
they don't even worry about it they
think inflation sources it doesn't I
can't because it's it's just just to
clarify that was your problem with the
inflation describing some ass
but those yes moments right after the
Big Bang inflation we're supposed to
stretch it out make it all uniform you
see it doesn't do it because you can
only do it if it's uniform already at
the beginning it's it's you just have a
look I can't go into the details but it
doesn't solve this and it was completely
clear to me it doesn't solve well word
is the conformal cyclic cosmology of
yeah we're starting to talk about
something before
yes that's singular I began I was just
thinking of myself how boring this
universe is going to be you've got this
exponential expansion this was
discovered early in the in this century
20th 21st century people discovered that
these supernovae exploding stars showed
that the universe is actually undergoing
this exponential expansion so it's a
self-similar expansion and it seems to
be a feature of this term that Einstein
introduced into his cosmology for the
wrong reason he wanted a universe that
was static he put this new term into his
cosmology and to make it make sense it's
called the cosmological constant and
then when he got convinced that the
universe had the Big Bang he retracted
it complaining this was his greatest
blunder the trouble is it wasn't a
blunder it was actually right very
ironic and so the universe seems to be
behaving with this cosmological constant
okay so this universe is expanding and
expanding what's going to happen in the
future well it gets more and more boring
from well what's the most interesting
thing in the universe well there's black
holes the black holes more or less
gulped down the entire clusters of
galaxies the class it'll swallow up most
of our galaxy we will run into Andromeda
galaxies black hole that black hole will
swallow em they will get bigger and
bigger and they'll basically swallow up
the whole cluster of galaxies golf it
all down pretty well all most of it
maybe not all most of it okay
that'll happen too there'll be just
these black holes around pretty boring
but still not as boring as it's going to
get it's going to get more boring
because these black holes you wait you
wait and you wait and you wait and wait
and unbelievable length of time and
Hawking's black hole evaporation
starts to come in and the black holes
you just it's a clarity Deus
finally evaporate away each one goes
away it disappears with the pop at the
end what could be more boring that it
was boring then now this is really
boring there's nothing not even black
holes universe gets colder and colder
and colder and colder and ever this is
very very boring now that's not science
is it but it's it's emotional so I
thought who's going to be bored by this
universe not us we won't be around it'll
be mostly photons running around and
what the photons do they don't get bored
because it's a part of relativity you
see it's not really that they don't
experience anything that's not the point
the photons get right out to infinity
without experience anytime it's the way
for them where your relativity works and
this was part of what I used to do in my
old days when I was looking
gravitational radiation and how things
behaved infinity infinity is just like
another place you can squash it down as
long as you don't have any mass in the
world infinity is just another place the
photons get there the gravitons get
there what do they get they've run to
infinity
they say well now I'm here what way
there's something on the other side is
there the usual view it's just a
mathematical notion there's nothing on
the other side that's just the boundary
of it a nice example is this beautiful
series of pictures by the Dutch artist
MC Escher you may know them the ones
called circle limits they're very famous
one with the angels and the Devils and
you can see them crowding and crowding
and crowding up to the edge now the kind
of geometry that these angels and devils
and habits that's their infinity but
from our perspective infinity is just a
point is a place ok there it is I can
you just take a brief pause yes and the
in just the word you're saying infinity
is just a place so I have for the most
part infinity sort of even just going
back yeah infinity is a mathematical
concept I think this is what I think
there's an actual physical manifestation
in which way does infinity ever
manifests itself in our physical
universe what it does in various places
you see
it's the thing that we're if you're not
a mathematician you think aren't
finished yeah I can't think about that
mathematicians think about affinity all
the time they get used to the idea and
they just play around with different
kinds of infinities and it becomes no
problem but yeah you just have to take
my word for it now one of the things is
you see you have taken Euclidian
geometry well it just keeps on keeps on
keeps on going and it goes out to
infinity now there are other kinds of
geometry and this is a what's called
hyperbolic geometry it's a bit like
Euclidean geometry so it'll be different
it's like what Asia was trying to
describe in his angels and devils and he
learned about this from coxeter and he
think that's a very nice thing I try to
represent this infinity to this kind of
geometry so it's not quite Euclidean
John which is a bit like it that the
angels and the Devils inhabit and their
infinity mind this nice transformation
you squash the other infinity down so
you can draw it as this nice circle
boundary to their universe now from our
outside perspective we can see their
infinity as this boundary now what I'm
saying is that it's very like that the
infinity that we might experience like
the angels and devils in their world can
be thought of as a boundary now I found
this a very useful way of talking about
radiation gravitational radiation and
things like that it was a trick
mathematical trick so no what I'm saying
is that that mathematical trick becomes
real that somehow the photons they need
to go somewhere because for their from
their perspective infinity it's just
another place now this is a difficult
idea to get your mind around so that's
why Kozma one of the reasons because
mom's just are finding a lot of trouble
taking me seriously
but to me it's not not such a wild idea
what's on the other side of that
infinity you have to think why am I
allowed to think of this because photons
don't have any mass and we in physics
have beautiful ways of measuring time
there are incredibly precise clocks
atomic and nuclear clocks unbelievably
precise while they be so precise because
of the two most famous equations of 20th
century physics one of them is Einsteins
e equals mc-squared what's that tell us
energy and mass are equivalent the other
one is even older than that still 20th
century only just Max Planck e equals H
nu nu is a frequency H is a constant
again Lexie E is energy energy and
frequency are equivalent put the two
together energy and mass equivalent
Einstein and in frequency equivalent Max
Planck put the D together mass and
frequency are equivalent absolutely
basic physical principle if you have a
massive entity a massive particle it is
a clock with a very very precise
frequency it's not you can't directly
use it you have to scale it down so your
atomic and nuclear clocks but that's the
basic principle you scale it down to
something you can actually perceive but
it's the same principle if you have mass
you have beautiful clocks but the other
side of that coin is if you don't have
mass you don't have clocks if you don't
have clocks you don't have rulers you
don't have scale so you don't have space
and time you don't have a measure of the
scale of space and all scale you have if
that you do have the structure that
what's called the conformal structure
you see it's what the angels levels have
if you look at the eye of the devil no
matter how close to the boundary it is
it has the same shape but it has a
different size so you can scale up and
you can scale down but you mustn't
change the shape so it's basically the
same idea but applied to space-time now
in the very remote future you have
things which don't measure the scale but
the shape if you like is still there now
that's in the remote future now I'm
going to do the exact opposite now I'm
going to go way back into the Big Bang
now as you get there things go hotter
and hotter denser and denser
what the universe dominated by particles
moving around almost with the speed of
light when they get almost with the
speed of light okay they begin to lose
the mass to therefore a completely
opposite reason they lose the sense of
scale as well so my crazy idea is the
Big Bang and a remote future they seem
completely different one is extremely
dense extremely hot the other is very
very rarefied and very very cold but if
you squash one down by this conformal
scale and you get the other so although
they look and feel very different
they're really almost the same the
remote future on the other side and
claiming is that one of the photons go
they go into the next Big Bang you've
got to get your mind around that crazy
idea taking a step on the other side of
the place that is infinity yes but I'm
saying the other side of our Big Bang
now I'm going back into the Big Bang
that was the remote future of a
previously on previously on and what I'm
saying is that previously on there are
signals coming through to us which we
can see and which we do see and these
are both signals the two main signals
are to do with black holes one of them
is the collisions between black holes
and as they spiral into each other they
release a lot of energy in the form of
gravitational waves those gravitational
waves get through in a certain form into
the next DM that's fascinating that
there's some I mean maybe I'm maybe you
can correct me if I'm wrong but that
means that some information can travel
yes from another eon exactly that that
is fascinating I mean I've seen
somewhere described sort of the
discussion of the Fermi paradox you know
that if there's intelligent life yes
being you know communication me
immediately takes you there so we have a
paper I have my my colleague waha
Gossage on who I work with this on these
ideas for a while we have a crazy paper
on that yes
so the family paradoxes right so so if
the universe is just cycling over and
over and over punctuated by have the
punctuated the singularity of the Big
Bang and then intelligent or any kind of
intelligent systems can communicate
through from e on T on why haven't we
heard anything from our alien friends
because we don't know how to look that's
fundamentally the reason is we I don't
know you see it's it's speculation I
mean the SETI program was a reasonable
thing to do but still speculation it's
trying to say ok maybe not too far away
with a civilization which got there
first before us early enough that they
could send our signals but how far away
would you need to go before I mean I
don't know we with so little knowledge
about that we haven't seen any signals
yet but it's worth looking it's worth
looking and what I'm trying to say
here's another possible place we might
look now you're not looking at
civilizations which got there first
you're looking at those civilizations
which were so successful probably a lot
more successful more likely to be man
looks of things which knew how to handle
their own global warming or whatever it
is and to get through it all and to live
to a ripe old age in the sense of a
civilization to the extent that they
could harness signals that they could
propagate through for some reason of
their own desires whatever we wouldn't
know to to other civilizations which
might be able to pick up the signals but
what kind of signals would they be I
have a foggiest let me ask the question
yes what to you is the most beautiful
idea in physics or mathematics or the
art at the intersection of the two I'm
going to have to say complex analysis I
might have said infinities and one of
the most single most beautiful idea I
think was the fact that you can even
infinities of different sizes and so on
but that's anyway I think complex
analysis this goes it's got so much
magic in it it's a very simple idea
you take these you guys hope you do you
take numbers you take the integers and
then you fill them up into the fractions
and the real numbers you imagine you're
trying to measure a continuous line and
then you think of how you can solve
equations then what about x squared
equals minus 1 well there's no real
number which has to satisfies that so
you have to think of well there's a
number called I you think you invent it
well in a certain sense it's there
already but this number when you add
that square root of minus 1 to it you
have what's called the complex numbers
and they're an incredible system if you
like you put one little thing in you put
square root of -1 in and you get how
much benefit out of it all sorts of
things that you'd never imagined before
and it's that amazing or hiding there in
putting that square root of -1 in so in
the sense that's the most magical thing
I've seen in mathematics or physics and
it's in quantum mechanics and in quantum
mechanics for there already you might
think what's it doing there ok just a
nice beautiful piece of mathematics and
then suddenly we say nope it's the very
crucial basis of quantum mechanics so on
there and the way the world works so on
the question of whether math is
discovered or invented it sounds like
you may be suggesting that partially as
possible the math is indeed discovered
oh absolutely yes no it's more like
archeology than you might think
so let me ask the most ridiculous maybe
the most important question what is the
meaning of life what gives your life
fulfillment purpose happiness and
meaning why do you think we're here on
this given all the Big Bang and the
infinities of photons that we've told I
would say I think it's not a stupid
question I mean there are some people
you know many of my colleagues new
scientists they say well that's a stupid
question meaning yeah well we just hear
because things came together and produce
life and so what I think there's more to
it but what there is that's more to it
really much idea it might be somehow
connected to the mechanisms of
consciousness though we're talking about
the mystery there
it's connected with all sortsa yeah I
think these things are tied up in ways
which er you see I tend to think the
mystery of consciousness is tied up with
the mystery of quantum mechanics and how
it fits in with the classical world and
that's all to do with the mystery of
quantum of complex numbers and there are
mysteries there which I look like
mathematical mysteries but they seem to
have a bearing on the way the physical
world operates we're scratching the
surface we have a long huge way to go
before we really understand that and
it's a beautiful idea that the the the
depth the mathematical depth could be
discovered and then there's tragedies of
Gaydos and completeness along the way
they will have to somehow figure our
ways around yeah so Roger as a huge
honour to talk to you thank you so much
for your time today everything my
pleasure thank you
thanks for listening to this
conversation with roger penrose and
thank you to a presenting sponsor at
Cash app please consider supporting this
podcast by getting expressvpn and
expressvpn comm / flex pod and
downloading cash app and using collects
podcast if you enjoy this podcast
subscribe I need to review it with five
stars and napa podcasts supported on
patreon or simply connect with me on
Twitter at lex friedman and now let me
leave you with some words of wisdom that
roger penrose wrote in his book the
emperor's new mind beneath all this
technicality is the feeling that it is
indeed quote unquote obvious that the
conscious mind cannot work like a
computer even though much of what is
involved in mental activity might do so
this is the kind of obvious that a child
can see though the child may later in
life become browbeaten into believing
that the obvious problems are quote
unquote non problems to be argued into
non-existence by careful reasoning and
clever choices of definition children
sometimes see things clearly that are
obscured in later life we often forget
the wonder that we felt as children on
the cares of the quote unquote
real world have begun to settle on our
shoulders children are not afraid to
post basic questions that might
embarrass us as adults to ask what
happens to each of our streams of
consciousness after who died where was
it before we were born
might we become or have been someone
else why do we perceive at all why are
we here why is there a universe here at
all in which we can actually be these
are puzzles that tend to come with the
awakenings of awareness in any of us and
no doubt will the awakening of
self-awareness within which ever
creature or other entity first came
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time
you